et on va plus loin avec zimam directeur
du mensuel Afrique Magazine bonjour Ziad
bonsoir Afrique Magazine quitte ce
mois-ci un pour novembre sur la Côte
d'Ivoire face à ces menaces
septentrionales avec l'opération Grand
Nord et puis aussi on le voit en bas à
gauche sur Karim Benzema Ballon d'Or et
Sadio Mané prise Socrate 2022 dans
l'occasion de parler football justement
dans cette émission Antoine Mariotti de
la rédaction de France 24 est également
avec nous chroniqués international
bonjour Antoine bonjour Raphaël un
Broglio autour d'un missile celui qui a
tué deux personnes hier dans le village
polonais de chez vaudouf à une dizaine
de kilomètres de la frontière avec
l'Ukraine après avoir cru dans un
premier temps un tir possible de la
Russie les puissances occidentales
États-Unis et Pologne en tête semblent
disculpés Moscou de manière assez
formelle d'ailleurs écoutez le Premier
ministre polonais Angelina
rien absolument rien n'indique qu'il
s'agisse d'une attaque intentionnelle
contre la Pologne ce qu'il s'est passé
le fait que sur notre territoire une
requête soit tombée n'était pas une
action intentionnelle ce n'était pas une
requête qui visait la Pologne donc ce
n'était pas une attaque contre la
Pologne
la question essentielle ici est de quel
type de missile s'agit-il
il s'agit très probablement d'un missile
de fabrication russe
produit très probablement dans les
années 70 qui est responsable du
lancement de ce missile à l'heure
actuelle nous n'avons aucune preuve
qu'il s'agit d'un missile tiré par les
Russes
mais il y a une forte probabilité donc
il s'agisse d'une requête utilisée par
les forces de défense ukrainienne
problème volodime zellenski le président
ukrainien lui reste persuadé que le
missile tombait en Pologne et l’œuvre de
la Russie et pour le prouver il réclame
l'accès immédiat au site de l'explosion
écouter déjà ce qu'il déclarait des hier
des missiles sur le territoire de l'OTAN
est une attaque russe contre la sécurité
collective c'est une escalade très
importante nous devons agir je veux dire
maintenant à tous nos frères et soeurs
polonais l'Ukraine vous soutiendra
toujours les gens libres ne seront pas
brisés par la terreur
va-t-il trop vite en besogne veut-il
nous faire entrer en guerre sa guerre
contre la Russie en tous les cas il a
été assez vite en décalage avec le
message qui est Mané le plus important
étant celui de Washington le reste
s'organise en fonction de ça qui était
de dire en gros un même si c'est un
missile russe qui s'est perdu on n'est
pas dans le cadre d'une confrontation
immédiate et de très rapidement au bout
de quelques heures il y a un vrai doute
donc cette espèce de décalage
on sent bien que d'un côté on a voulu
mettre le frein pour pas que ça
s'emballe pour pas qu'il y a des gens
qui ont parlé sur Twitter de d'une
nouvelle crise des missiles de Cuba que
le monde allait basculer dans la nuit
que enfin tout le monde était très très
énervé et il y a tout de suite eu ce ce
message
américain centré sur le wait and see et
je pense que
même du point de vue crainien je pense
que c'est un peu une diversion parce en
fait quel que soit x ça reste quand même
un problème lié à la Russie que ça soit
un missile ukrainien qui soit qui soit
malveillé Washington d'ailleurs
du coup on va si on se met à compter non
tout ça c'est lié à l'attaque russe et
donc celui-ci il a pas visé la Pologne
il a visé un missile entre en
probablement et il était des débris sont
tombés du mauvais côté mais je pense
qu'il faut pas rentrer dans ce procès là
la discussion elle est claire il y a un
pays attaqué il y a un pays attaquant et
donc tous les dégâts collatéraux y
compris ceux qui peuvent entraîner
l'Europe et les États-Unis dans une
escalade sont quand même assez largement
du côté russe ça faibli à Antoine la
position de volodime zellenski alors que
faut le rappeler je viens de le faire
l'Ukraine a tout de même vécu hier sa
pire journée de bombardement depuis
l'invasion ah oui puis on parlait de ça
puis c'est une journée de bombardements
dans 12 régions d'Ukraine donc dans tout
le pays compris elles vivent qu'il y a à
peu près 125 km de cette ville de chez
Vaudaux chez vos doudouf je vais y
arriver évidemment où a eu lieu ce
missile ça affaibli parce qu'en effet il
a eu un premier message hier qui était
vraiment entendu ce n'est rien d'autre
un message de la Russie adressé au
sommet du G20 la rue si était le
responsable et l'entité qui avait envoyé
celui-ci son chef de la diplomatie il
dit carrément que si on parle de missile
ukrainien ce sont des théories du
complot et puis aujourd'hui on va vous
dire
hier mais maintenant avec les éléments
qu'on a il aurait pu revenir
aussi sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous disent
pas ces russes mais ils disent ce n'est
pas ukrainien il y a une légère nuance
qui a été ce soir il la redire à
interfaces en tout cas un rapport de ses
propos de Zelenski qui dit c'est russe
et dit surtout c'est pas ukrainien et il
a des différences un peu
d'interprétation et de traduction mais
il demande aussi un accès immédiat à la
zone pour aller enquêter avec les
Polonais les Polonais on dit ouh là
attendez nous on est d'accord mais
seulement si les États-Unis veulent bien
que vous veniez donc quand il y a des il
y a 2 secondes que tous décidé aussi
avec Washington c'est un autre exemple
les propos apaisants de Varsovie n'ont
pas empêché derrière c'est très curieux
à la Russie de convoquer l'ambassadeur
polonais à Moscou pourquoi il y a de la
Russie prend la prise de tendre encore
la situation alors que les faits
semblent aller plutôt dans son sens ces
dernières heures oui mais comme
l'argumentation c'est vous nous avez
provoqué en nous accusant
hystérie antirus tatati tatata bon c'est
dans le jeu presque normal du Kremlin
pour le coup les occidentaux on fait
plutôt propre de retenue oui mais bon ça
empêche pas que la Pologne ira passer un
mauvais moment au ministère des Affaires
étrangères russes je pense que c'est
assez anecdotique dans le dans le global
de cette histoire où les Russes jouent
en permanence la stratégie de
l'attention et joue en permanence la
division du camp occidental et on est à
peu près raccord sur ça c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on s'aperçoit que ce camp
occidental il se fissure assez peu même
si certains pays les opinions publiques
bougent mais mais finalement pas
fondamentalement et puis surtout il y a
un centre un pivot de ce camp occidental
qui est celui qui donne le tempo de la
discussion c'est à Washington que ça se
passe et on l'a bien vu au G20 on le
voit c'est-à-dire si Washington utilise
certains mots on va vers cette direction
si Washington utilise d'autres mots on
va verser de direction et donc là voilà
donc les Russes jouent leur partition
ils ont fait aussi oublier le fait
qu'ils ont bombardé de manière assez
aveugle comme vous disiez plus de 100
missiles qui sont tombés sur des zones
urbaines sur des centrales électriques
etc
tout ça est passé dans le dans le début
de la Troisième Guerre mondiale et et
finalement ils s'en sortent pas si mal
au final cette crise dans la crise aura
été l'occasion Antoine pour l'OTAN
d'afficher sa rapidité de réaction et à
faire front commun ou au contraire la
crainte d'un affrontement avec Moscou
parce qu'on a senti quand même des hier
que personne n'y avait réellement
intérêt à ce que ces missiles soient
envoyés par la Russie personne n'y a
intérêt mais on voit bien que tout le
monde est dans les starting blocks et
c'est vrai qu'on entend de suite parler
de Troisième Guerre mondiale bon il faut
un peu raison garder parfois aussi
donc oui évidemment faut faire faut être
prudent après clairement le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN a énormément assisté
là-dessus dans sa conférence de presse
ce matin il refusait de donner le
moindre détail ne serait-ce que de
savoir s'il y avait un missile russe
dans la zone si ce missile probablement
ukrainien c'était avec explosé en vol ou
au sol rien que ce genre de détail il
refusait de le donner par contre il
insistait beaucoup vous voyez l'OTAN est
tout à fait préparé à ce genre de choses
nous réagissons vite etc bon la réaction
elle a été surtout de d'enquêter d'avoir
des premières éléments satellitaires
sans doute et très probablement qu'il
venait notamment des États-Unis même
s'il est belge ou autre se sont
prononcés et de dire voilà le leitmotiv
un peu pour aller dans le sens ce que
vous disiez c'est vraiment surtout pas
d'escalade du côté de Washington on ne
veut pas le troisième guerre mondiale
Joe Biden a relié quelques jours on ne
va certainement pas envoyer des avions
dans le ciel
ukrainien affronter ceux des Russes
alors que eux-mêmes les Ukrainiens nous
demandent d'envoyer des avions donc
c'est vraiment un peu la sur le
frein pour que ça ne s'envenime pas plus
que ça ne l'est déjà on a eu le
sentiment l'espace d'une nuit néanmoins
de vivre un moment d'y être comparable à
la crise des euromissiles ou missiles de
Cuba presque c'est une réalité
c'est-à-dire qu'on est en une annonce
sur ce fil de l'escalade des escalades
il suffit qu'il y ait un incident on le
sait dans toutes les guerres il suffit
qu'un avion tombe du mauvais côté il
suffit qu'un pilote tire du mauvais côté
il suffit il suffit de rien pour que
tout tout puisse partir en bride donc
forcément hier il y a eu un moment où ça
après on pourrait aussi se dire que si
les ruches chercher une provocation
c'était pas avec un quart de missile sur
sur un village bon il y a eu deux
victimes c'est clair mais si on
cherchait une provocation vis-à-vis de
le temps pour est-ce pour avoir un
moment de pour monter en intensité on
aurait peut-être choisi une cible
différente où on aurait quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus spectaculaire
peut-être j'en sais rien en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est une ferme c'est pas
une centrale électrique ou autre ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on est en permanence
dans cette affaire sur la ligne et que
ça peut basculer sur sur un dérapage qui
peut prendre des proportions c'est une
guerre on s'habitue à cette guerre mais
ça reste une guerre qui met une des
puissances nucléaires les plus
importantes au monde de la Russie face à
un camp occidental où il y a l'autre
puissance nucléaire la plus importante
au monde c'est une autre compétition à
Pacifique celle là qui m'étoile pour la
dernière fois dans ce format 32 équipes
de football elle a Coupe du Monde début
dimanche au Qatar les français eux sont
arrivés sur place aujourd'hui à
difficile à ne parler du Qatar sans
évoquer la polémique faut-il assister
aux rencontres au contraire les
boycottés comme l'ont déjà décidé des
villes comme Paris Marseille Lyon
Bordeaux encore Toulouse ici en France
qui ne vont pas retransmettre la
compétition sur l'écran géant comme
c'est pourtant devenu la coutume Antoine
c'est une bonne question boycot ou pas
en tout cas toutes ces polémiques tout
ce bruit qu'il y a eu avec la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar on peut avoir peut-être
un espoir si on cherche un côté positif
c'est que on arrêtera de confier
l'organisation d'un tel événement à ce
genre de pays sans être regardant etc
est-ce que j'y crois foncièrement pas
tellement je pense qu'on oublie vite on
avait eu des polémiques moments de la
Chine en 2008 pour les Jeux Olympiques
on a oublié après
etc donc voilà après concrètement est-ce
que les joueurs doivent boycotter parce
que le boycott il peut avoir plein de
manières différentes est-ce que les
joueurs doivent boycotter je trouve
personnellement que ce serait un peu
fort de leur remettre ça sur le dos
c'est quand même pas eux qui ont choisi
voilà en revanche est-ce que des gestes
symboliques de leur part ce serait les
bienvenus sans doute est-ce que il faut
boycotter dans les grandes villes les
écrans géantes comme on a pu voir à
Paris bon on s'aperçoit qu'il y a quand
même une grande démagogie là-dessus
surtout dans une ville où le principal
club de foot et et propriété du Qatar ou
ceux qui ne vont pas regarder sur
l'écran gérant ils vont prendre un
abonnement chez BeIn Sport qui est
propriété du Qatar donc bon tout ça est
un peu démagogique est-ce qu'il faut en
revanche que les spectateurs
s'abstiennent de se rendre sur place moi
je trouve pas ça complètement illogique
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais enfin ça
a du sens quand même et enfin ce qu'il
faut que les politiques boycott c'est
sans doute ce qui empêcherait en
betterait le plus les dirigeants
cathariens qui font quand même tout ça
pour leur soft power pour leur image
leur vitrine faut pas oublier que bon
tout ça c'est sûr des centaines ou
milliers de morts le chiffre exact
d'ailleurs que le propre président de la
à l'époque de l'attribution avait dit
qu'il avait à amèrement regretté
j'ai plein de regrets amers après coup
moi ce qui me perturbe dans cette
histoire que le Qatar est un certain
nombre de dossiers de problèmes sur le
plan des droits de l'homme sur le plan
des minorités sur le plan des minorités
religieuses ou des minorités
LGBT ou de l'expression général qui par
ailleurs n'est pas propre au Qatar c'est
propre à toute la région et si on
cherchait des exemples de travailleurs
migrants maltraités on n'a pas besoin
d'aller jusqu'au Qatar on peut aller en
Inde on peut aller dans leur propre
cuisine ce qui est gênant dans cette
histoire c'est cette espèce de
surgressivité sur le dossier qui est
très heureux américaine et bah faut même
pas American qui est très européenne et
il y a un problème cathare ce truc là
c'est quoi ce pays qui riche qui se
permet qui est musulman pays arabes
pourquoi on fait ça là-bas
cette perception là est totalement
rejetée dès que vous changez
d'hémisphère vous allez en Isère Sud les
gens vous disent mais de quoi vous
parlez alors il faut jamais faire de
coupe du monde dans l'hémisphère sud
parce qu'il fait trop chaud en hiver en
été on pourra pas faire l'hiver si on
n'est pas assez nombreux on peut pas la
faire etc donc il y a quand même moi je
trouve un problème de perception et et
qui est lié au fait que c'est cette ce
petit Emirat musulman arabe riche ça
fait til til til tit à tous les étages
il y a la question des travailleurs ça
je suis d'accord et je pense que
la pression des ONG d'Amnesty de tout ça
va finir par faire bouger quelque chose
et des choses ont déjà bougé au kata
sous le projecteur du Mondial est plutôt
positif de changer les choses plus que
dans les autres émirats et la dernière
chose je rappelle que quand la Russie a
fait la Coupe du monde on est tous allé
faire la bringue à Moscou et à
Saint-Pétersbourg ah oui sans se poser
de questions alors qu'il venait de
prendre l'Ukraine et que il venait de
prendre la Crimée et qu'ils avaient rasé
la moitié de la Syrie donc franchement
il y a un moment on se dit et la Chine
elle fait des Jeux olympiques d'hiver en
mettant de la neige
que les gens ne comprennent pas dans
l'autre hémisphère la question est celle
du timing je peux me permettre c'est à
dire que on s'indigne beaucoup à
quelques semaines du début de la
compétition mais c'est peut-être avant
de confier l'organisation au Qatar oui
mais très peu par rapport à ce qui se
passe c'est ces dernières semaines
c'est-à-dire que il y a très très
longtemps je dis ça parce que d'une
pétition
Zidane a reconnu lui-même avoir touché
des millions de d'euros pour pour avoir
promu le truc de l'organisation du
Mondial au Qatar bon euh on touche pas
une légende de la polémique
les gens d'une génération précédente se
rappelle qu'on a joué une coupe du monde
en Argentine chez les généraux dans une
dictature prochaine c'est toujours la
prochaine la prochaine se jouera dans
trois démocraties États-Unis Canada
Mexique
mais sur le plan écologique c'est une
catastrophe de faire une coupe du monde
à 48 en plus je crois 48 pays sur trois
sur trois pays avec les avions les
machins donc là on en parlait en
préparant l'émission on peut on peut
dire c'est qu'il y a s'il y a une vraie
discussion c'est sur le gigantisme de
ces événements dans une aire où il faut
un peu d'austérité et du changement
climatique ça c'est une vraie discussion
que ça soit les JO que ce soit la Coupe
du monde que ce soit tous ces grands et
ça concerne donc aussi la France
organisatrice des jeux 2024 merci il y a
l'imam merci également Antoine Mariotti
c'était on va plus loin on se retrouve
dans un peu plus de 3 minutes pour un
nouveau journal rester avec nous
merci
[Musique]